huh all right  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [ __ ] together too much confidence now  like my skin is a big deal Anglo  features are a big deal like I have  green eyes from my imperialism nobody my  family even cares how attack my three  eyes from they'd be like your brick  grandma took one for the team  you guys married I see a ring on your  finger  okay that's what's up me too okay  [Applause]  like know anything girls put pressure on  that's they don't give a [ __ ]  how're you guys dating beforehand 30  years yeah that's my girl 3 plus and she  started putting pressure on me like 6  months and it was great see I've got  good we've only been dating 6 months and  she'd be like that's the 6 miles longer  than our parents knew together why can  you guess the face